so again your Alibi is a mysterious
stranger handed you the gun made you put
your prints on it robbed the store and
then hid the gun in your underpants Well
yeah if you say it like that it don't
sound believable oh hey Captain did you
get my report on the Finley murder uh
yeah looked it over nice word good
thanks Dad
why is everyone staring at me you just
called Captain hold dad he said thanks
Dad what no I didn't I said thanks man
do you see me as a father figure Peralta
no if anything I see you is a bother
figure because you're always bothering
me hey show your father some respect I
didn't call him Dad no no no no Jacob I
take it as a compliment it's not a big
deal I called Vivian mom once she's my
fiance guys jump on that Boyle has
psychosexual issues old news but you
calling Holt daddy daddy is not on the
table here but you did call him dead
dude you shut up you've done nothing but
lie since you got here all right all
right I was lying about the holdup but
the dad thing that happened
he admitted that his Alibi was a lie it
was a trap all part of my crazy devious
plan I believe you thank you son
you want to talk about it later over uh
dim the catch
I'd like that you know in a weird way
I'm gonna miss our little house yes and
in an even weirder way I think I might
actually miss you oh and in an even
weirder way I want you guys to be my
dads that is weirder yeah I got stuff my
dad's coming into town and we're going
out to dinner tonight why are you going
to dinner with him he hasn't visited you
in six years yeah he's busy he's an
airline pilot Regional Airline he flies
internationally well back to Albany what
is going on here what's your problem
with my Dad I'm just being wary he left
you when you were seven he's been
letting us down ever since us I think if
he was her brother Jake so he didn't
just abandon you he abandoned us look I
know he hasn't been the best dad in the
past but he's changed check it out we've
been texting him new phone who dis no
below that oh hey Captain Holt come meet
my dad Captain Peralta hello captain
captain
this is super weird for me
Jake
I'm sorry I could make it to the party
I'm subbing for a buddy who's got an
early flight I'm sure you're upset
actually I'm not upset at all yeah
right no we're relieved
you know you were always my hero but I
think I'm finally starting to see you
for who you really are a regional
airline pilot whose Landings are bumpy
as hell and a pretty selfish guy who
genuinely doesn't care about being a dad
Jake you don't understand
there was a downdraft on the
Drummondville Runway
it's not my fault yeah clearly look I've
been making excuses for you my whole
life
but you're a pretty crappy father
and until you're ready to be a good one
don't call me
also I'm taking your captain because
it's cool and I want it
[Music]
you two have kids mixed race babies are
always so adorable ah you've said words
yeah we don't have kids yet but we're
gonna start trying soon I just have the
one my Bobby he was such a cute little
kid until he discovered his weiner Pam
there you are it's time for your IV
you're playing music in here you can't
do that why not nurse Janet is it gonna
distract the doctors yes that's exactly
what it'll do okay fine I'll turn it off
immediately
are we the bad guys here yeah it seems
very likely hey by the way we don't have
to pretend we're undercover here the
hospital staff knows we're cops oh I
wasn't setting up cover was I well just
the kids thing saying that we were gonna
start trying soon oh I'm sorry I didn't
mean right away I just meant in the near
future oh
except for that there's one little
problem there which is that I don't know
that I totally know that I for sure want
to have kids
so okay fine you want to know why I
really don't want to have children
I had a crappy dad
I know what happens when you mess up as
a parent it's not great and this may
come as a shock to you but
I kind of have some dad issues with
certain people yeah but not just him
it's every male authority figure for my
entire life Hey Jake can you move
Legends of the Fall From new releases to
drama you got it dad Craig was only six
weeks older than me okay look Amy I'm
scared okay I'm scared that we're gonna
have a child and I won't be able to
handle it I'm scared that I'm not going
to be a good father and I'm scared that
I'll make a mistake I can't take back
I've been thinking and I do want to have
kids
with you
you're not scared anymore oh no I am so
scared maybe even more so than before
but I was scared in there with Pam too
and you know I didn't Panic or mess
anything up there if anything I was
sharper it was a freaking debate genius
oh that's very hot that's an added bonus
okay keep that energy up but the point
that I was actually trying to make is
maybe it's a good thing that I'm scared
of fatherhood you know maybe it'll turn
me into a friggin dad genius he was
pretty intense
give me catching the shooter I know it's
a great story I just hope Pitt can get
in good enough shape to play me in the
movie you know yeah
um also something else happened
I thought I might be pregnant really
yeah I'm not I got my period And I took
a pregnancy test but it didn't work
because I drank 11 gallons of water told
you water was bad for you it's not the
takeaway you're absolutely right how are
you how do you feel you okay I mean I
was really stressed this wasn't our plan
and we agreed we'd wait a year and
there's so much to do first and it would
have been crazy right yeah it would have
been
but
also might have been
kind of cool
honestly
I was secretly bummed when the test came
back negative
should we just start trying seriously
yeah seriously
okay
[Music]
Mario why are you like this hey so I
don't know if you noticed but ever since
I started those hormone treatments I
didn't notice anything
you said that way too quick I mean you
did cry at that one car commercial and
it wasn't even an emotional one it was
about towing capacity yeah well I called
the doctor to see if that was a common
side effect and apparently it isn't
oh no is everything okay yeah she did
have one guess as to what might be
causing it and um she was right
oops
are we having a baby we're having a baby
foreign
[Music]
well we did it Ames
we made the world's hottest baby
cute Jake nope this kid is Liquid Fire
crazy to think in just 17 short years
he's gonna be six foot seven and the
number one draft pick for the Knicks and
then he's gonna pass up that opportunity
to pursue his true passion Library
Sciences well the important thing is
we'll support him no matter what
even if he's a huge huge nerd
are we gonna be okay at this
I mean this entire day felt like a
warning from the Universe I almost
missed the birth we had our baby at the
precinct a firefighter touched our child
we washed him off yeah but I'll always
know Terry Terry it's him it's really
frenzy don't ask how I know because it
has nothing to do with lamps Jake what
are you doing here what are you doing
here you're supposed
to care
oh Amy what is that enchanting new
perfume it's syrup Scully and it is
working hmm
I think you just made Scully horny I had
to go here with Mac fine mellow he
pulled himself up wait what
I just figured you would be bummed that
you missed it
sucks you didn't get to arrest Francia I
didn't get to see Mac pull up I guess we
really can't do it all I don't know I
mean you got to do the work thing and I
got to do the parent thing so
together
we did do it all
it still totally sucks though yeah I'm
really bummed
get ready for bed
you're gonna wake up mac and see if
he'll pull up aren't you obviously he's
not sleeping until he does it it's an
amazing plan babe thank you very much
and everyone's going to be so shocked
when they find out the big surprise
that I'm leaving the 99.
what did you just say
yeah
what do you mean you're leaving I mean
that's what I want to do but only if you
agree I don't understand it well for
weeks we've been trying to figure out
how you can do your new job and still
have us be there for Mac as much as we
want and I really think this is it yeah
but we have other options yeah
but I think this is the best one
look you know I was scared about having
kids because I didn't want to be like my
dad
but if I do this I have a chance to be
the exact opposite and I don't want Mac
to ever feel the way I felt growing up
on my first day here I asked Jeffers to
tell me about everyone told me you were
a great detective but the one thing you
couldn't figure out was how to grow up
well
I think you finally figured it out
well thank you sir I couldn't have done
it without you over the years you've
sometimes referred to me as something of
a father figure did I I didn't realize
that but I want you to know if I had had
a son
and uh it turned out like you
I would be very proud of them
thank you sir